Dion Sanders has proven that being petty
can actually Rack in a boatload of cash
and now he is over a million dollars
richer in just one day before Saturday's
game against Colorado State csu's head
coach Jay Norvell basically called
Dion's classic hat and shades look
childish he said his mother taught him
to take his hat and sunglasses off when
he talks to grown-ups Dion took his
comment and ran with it he responded by
not only handing out sunglasses from his
blenders line to the entire team before
their matchup against Colorado State but
he doubled down and gave the glasses to
the on-air crew to wear on TV before the
game coach primes rebuttal led to 1.2
million dollars in sales in just one day
cashing in yet another w